a suspect is in custody in connection with
the stabbing deaths of Ford University of
Idaho students last month authorities sorted
through thousands of tips and tracked Brian
coburger more than 2 000 miles away from the
murder scene to his parents home in Pennsylvania's
Pocono Mountains as Donya Backus reports police
are trying to determine a motive for the killings
what I can tell you is we have a individual
in custody who committed these horrible crimes
after 19 000 tips in a quadruple murder case
that Drew Nationwide attention detectives
arrested 28 year old Brian Christopher coburger
coburger was arrested at his parents Pennsylvania
home the 28 year old is a PhD criminology
student at Washington State University just
a 10-minute drive to the Idaho campus kohlberg
is being held without bail and will spend
the weekend in Pennsylvania his extradition
back to Idaho expected next week the arrest
caps nearly seven weeks of fear and frustration
for families of the four murdered students
this is the first bit of joy that we've had
in close to seven weeks we hope that there's
they've picked they've picked the right guy
and that gives us hope and we haven't had
hope for a long time Kaylee Gonzalez Madison
mojin Zana Cardinal and Ethan Chapin All stabbed
multiple times as they slept and inside this
house near the campus despite surveillance
video showing the victims in the hours before
they were murdered and despite thousands of
tips pouring into the Moscow police department
they appeared at least publicly to be little
movement on the case no suspects no arrest
as the grief mounted and many students left
campus outside the house the caution tape
has finally come down no arrest will ever
bring back these young students however we
do believe Justice will be found through the
criminal process the district attorney who
will eventually prosecute kerberger once he's
back in Idaho says an arrest does not mean
an end to the investigation they are still
searching for tips from anyone who knows the
suspect we should know more after the extradition
hearing Tuesday in Pennsylvania for CBS Saturday
morning Donya Backus Moscow Idaho